il est 14h et d'habitude à cet or si le
parvis de la gare est noire de monde
en raison de la grève vous le voyez il
n'y a pas un chat et ça c'est un coup
dur pour les commerçants situés aux
abords des commerçants qui sont même
parfois inquiets pour la survie de leur
établissement mois la perte de clientèle
s'évalue à plus de 50% chaque jour de
grève et le lendemain matin des jours de
grève aussi c'est assez compliqué
comment vous organisez je demander une
rallonge à mon banquier première chose
comment je m'organisais écouter on fait
de l'administratif convaincu j'en fais
des formations s'occupe on ne reste pas
rien faire mais le loyer que je paye à
la gare lui reste fixe mais mes rentrées
d'argent elles ne sont pas là je ne sais
pas on va je sais pas un niveau de la
perte de chiffre d'affaires ne sais pas
si on peut on va continuer à tenir
on est là vous oui oui oui parce que
j'ai repris très peu de temps un même
pas un an donc la première année
d'activité c'est compliqué sale temps
aussi pour les taxis qui enregistrent
eux aussi une baisse de fréquentation
depuis maintenant quatre semaines
même si dit-il ils soutiennent le
mouvement des cheminots est ce que les
des conduits de la sncf ça vous profite
à vous taxi pas du tout non absolument
pas ça ne profite pas du tout parce
qu'il n'y a pas de train du coup pas de
gens qui arrivent en gare donc beaucoup
moins de transport pour nous voilà bah
ça nous laisse beaucoup de temps pour
dire les livres comme celui là les
intouchables de l'état pour apprendre
que monsieur pépy il gagne quatre cent
cinquante mille d'euros par an et qu'il
est à la tête de la sncf depuis 17 ans
et qui fait partie de ces privilégiés
qu'on s'occupe jamais plus surprenant la
grève sncf affecte aussi les loueurs de
voiture contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait imaginer
il ne se frotte pas tant les mains
personne n'a souhaité ici s'exprimer
face caméra mais en coulisses on nous a
confié que là aussi il y avait moins de
clients depuis quatre semaines et que là
aussi il y avait une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires